googling yourself may be easy but
changing what Google finds about you is
nearly impossible in fact it's so
difficult that many small businesses pay
tens and even hundreds of thousands of
dollars to get rid of negative comments
the companies that do this are known as
reputation management companies Jim
Axelrod is here with our investigation
into this growing online industry Jim
good morning good morning online
reputation management companies promised
digital magic to make negative webpages
disappear now while much of the work is
legitimate our CBS News investigation
unmasked the scheme in the industry that
very well may be criminal I'm here to
tell you what I can do for you is very
high what you're watching is a meeting
with hidden cameras CBS news producers
set up with John Rooney who runs web
savvy LLC one of those reputation
management firms that buries bad reviews
online look when it comes to this kind
of suppression quote unquote hiding
pushing downward it's dependent upon a
number of factors okay a lot of which
depends on Google reputation management
companies like these legally try to
trick Google by flooding the internet
with positive content about their
clients forcing negative lengths down to
Google's second and third pages where
almost nobody looks but that's not
foolproof
so John Bruni told us that some
companies employ other shadowy tactics
are there tricky ways to do it kind of
great areas if you will yeah I wouldn't
risk it I've seen it done one of the
only ways to get Google to permanently
remove a link is with a court order we
sorted through thousands of these court
orders and found all kinds of small
businesses across America trying to
clean up their reputations but we also
spotted a problem dozens of these court
orders were fake
I'd never even crossed my mind that
people would have the guts to actually
go out there and just forge a court
document as Eugene Vaali
UCLA law professor who specializes in
internet law points out forging a court
document is criminal part of it is also
just how brazen it is they take a
judge's signature
they copy it from one order to another
order and they pretend something as a
court order it's cheaper and it's faster
if they don't get caught we worked with
volley and identified more than 60
fraudulent court orders sent to Google
some are obviously fake like this one
with a case number of one two three four
five six seven eight nine others are
more sophisticated like these that
appear to be drawn from nine different
federal courts across the country if
somebody says I'm advertising guaranteed
removal service and I've seen that
advertised you should be suspicious it's
not just about making a bad review of
your local restaurant disappear we
uncovered bogus court documents
submitted on behalf of two convicted
criminals who wanted Google to forget
about their crimes both were child sex
offenders of the more than 60 phony
documents we found that 11 had
signatures forged from judges in of all
places
Hamilton County Ohio some of them were
pretty good forgeries frankly and some
of them were utterly terrible forgeries
after we brought the documents to Aftab
parov all the court clerk his office
launched an investigation
it's absolutely criminal one of those
fake Ohio documents was submitted for a
client who hired web-savvy LLC the
company run by John Rooney that's why we
invited him to meet us with our hidden
cameras rolling my name is Jim Axelrod
I'm with CBS News I want to ask you
questions about this contract you have
you recognize the name of the client
certainly do this appears to be a court
order same name of the client one
problem John this is fake its fraudulent
its phony
can you explain to me I can file that
never seen it before
is this a technique you have ever used
no I'm trying to figure out how the same
links that are in this contract that you
were paid $7,500 to remove end up in in
a fake court order with the clients name
I'm telling you I don't know the answer
to that question you understand how this
works
I do I appreciate your time but there's
nothing else to discuss we followed up
with Rooney after the meeting but he had
nothing more to say in response to our
reporting on those sixty fake document
federal prosecutors have sent at least
two cases to the FBI google declined our
request for an interview but they say
they do work hard to spot bad actors
trying to game the system mr. Rooney
held a straight face while you're
sitting there with if he didn't file it
who did well that's good question and I
think some people will be looking into
just that question they really may need
some reputation clean up online and you
know Jim I think one of the points that
I think we should stress is that I think
people when they hear this story they
think oh it's about a bad restaurant
review but your point here about
convicted criminals trying to wipe the
record clean is really doesn't get much
more serious than that thank you very
much companies